foreign
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
break room here at new Rockstar's
headquarters in Pacoima Washington yeah
that's where we are that's where we are
crazy check the reverse ID yeah we're
always making those Los Angeles
references to keep you off your toes we
hate L.A it's New York is La dying the
New York Times investigators yeah
Louisiana is my least favorite state in
the Union yeah oh are we naming the
least favorite steaks out of Jersey you
gave it away the garbage bin of the U.S
uh thank you to all our Breakers and
roomies we see you there in the chat we
hope you're having a great day coming up
on the show today Warner Brothers
retcons one of their own trailers in a
fascinating uh piece of editing uh and
hey that's not a headache you're feeling
it's scanners
yeah
so much of our audience going what is
this
and who might be swinging into She-Hulk
very soon we'll discuss it all this and
more joining me on the show today
someone's here someone tracked us down
so when someone's on to us uh if we get
caught up uh I didn't do it I'm innocent
wait a second it's The Vancouver Police
Department that makes sense
what'd you do now Tommy hey hey I stole
some maple syrup from a mountain
uh well why don't we introduce some
folks I'm Brandon who cares across the
table and we got koi John Dro known
scanners fan
we were talking about how that was a
movie we all saw too yeah yeah VHS
terrified that's right too for me
including Erica hey internet uh I don't
I've never seen scanners too but I've
seen scanner cop and scanner Cop 2 which
a lot of people don't know is a thing is
it attached to the universe
is there more than those standard
standard cop and uh I think it stopped
the scanner cop too but it also produced
in Canada I saw a super cop but that's
different it's different it's different
and that was awesome it's definitely in
the scanners world but yeah
inside that's right Michael Ironside my
old friend uh
how are you guys yeah don't report
people for calling people in the chat
trash they are trash that is what they
are it's a confusing thing that's like
saying that's like reporting people for
breathing the chat can't help but
they're in the dumpster yeah yeah don't
report them let them live let them live
let them decompose in their trash bins
let them live return to the Earth uh I
saw scanners too but for me it's scary
one I saw first in the Cronenberg
reverse was video drone oh and that
movie messed me up big time the big time
weirdly scary for me
weirdly scary but he rips on his feet
okay I guess it's literally
got some crazy writing credits but I
think Cronenberg if I am going to be him
like in like 2008 just took a writing
for higher I think he did uh I think
he's
a trap with Lindsay Lohan yeah let's go
with that yeah
uh well we're having a great time and we
hope you're having a great time in the
chat go ahead and hit that like button
if you haven't done it already and if
you want to send in super chats for
every 100 today in super chess we're
gonna be we're gonna spin the wheel of
of heroes and villains and give a toast
at their wedding you saw She-Hulk last
night it was a very wedding episode not
a very Daredevil episode but that's fine
folks who cares I don't even like two
dollars on betting on that he's got he's
got to show up eventually right
eventually they promised us uh the
greatest trick the Daredevil ever
it was convincing us
it's true it's true uh but yeah we'll
we'll be giving our own wedding toast
today I'm sure you've all been to a
wedding where the toast went so well oh
yeah so well it never goes wrong let me
tell you some stories about the groom
when he was a single wild man that guy
was hard all the time oh my gosh Grandpa
I'm not here
like Andrew Garfield
there wasn't a lot of Silence in our
hotel room that night oh my God but
Scorpio Daisy was there directing anyway
uh so yeah sending those super chats and
we'll we'll do a little uh wedding
toasting but before we get to all that
folks we got to get to it the headlines
hey
oh my gosh that was a half-hearted
they were so deeply I know we're deep in
this week we had to watch so much
midnight TV this week oh so much 16
episodes of and or dropped on Tuesday
yeah but we love it we love it all we do
love indoors at all uh our first
headline today Josh cigar I gave an
interview to E news in which he revealed
that the Cameo that must be in She-Hulk
he demands it well it's Spider-Man uh
and he's been he's been ringing this
Bell for a little while yeah he did this
at the shio premiere uh in this
interview he said quote pug in the comic
gets saved by Spider-Man and that's why
he dedicates his life to protecting
superheroes yeah uh yes it's a girl like
Tom segory
no one would have known Tommy but yeah
you're a fan of your words hey I don't
want anyone I don't want to be
intellectually dishonest I spelled Josh
segura's name wrong and then when I copy
and pasted it I spelled it right uh
you're you're a man of your word Tommy
that word is spelled wrong but you're a
manager
h-o-r-d he also went on to uh he was
kind of joking like yeah bring in like
Toby Spider-Man bring in just bring in
all this environment I mean I I applaud
the uh this actor's dedication to like
being like we got to get Spider-Man on
the show as if they're not done shooting
the show okay
he doesn't know that it could be good I
mean can you imagine a world where dress
like there's a scene where just like Tom
Holland walks by and like gives them a
little wing he doesn't have to say
anything I think he could get around a
lot of rules
in Spider-Man right Hugh Jackman just on
the street yeah yeah so then he wouldn't
have to be credited yeah yeah and that
was kind of like we would have shared
Universe years ago I mean I know this
he's just doing this for press he's
being a good little press boy it's
working I think there's a I mean I feel
like they're trying to set me up here
what if Daredevil is only in one scene
but Tom Holland's in the last two
episodes I mean that would be great
we've been Daredevil for five minutes if
all the footage of Daredevil we've seen
has been cut from the show what does it
always see yeah that scene we saw it at
uh it wouldn't make sense who Tom
Holland was so they could get away with
like a Shazam uh Superman thing and just
show someone in the Spider-Man suit
because all he knows is that Spider-Man
says that's right and everyone can wear
the mask it could be Dom and it could be
all sorts of spiders any Spiderman
Spiderman uh next headline according to
Screen Rant oh this was crazy Warner
Brothers and this this is true Warner
Brothers removed some footage from the
Black Adam trailer that they put out
yesterday and then put out a new trailer
under 24 hours basically they put out a
new Black Adam trailer yesterday if you
didn't see it now the rock tweeted it
and it was like oh uh black Adam's
coming and he's fitting in with all
these other heroes or something like
that and they showed uh like Batman's
Batarang they showed uh I think they
showed a name they showed an image of
Steppenwolf yeah from Joss whedon's
version of Justice red hammer like
hitting the ground which I think in the
Wheaton version or the Snyder version is
changed to being dark side whatever
Steppenwolf is like in a Apostle of
darts right right it was it had been
changed by weed so anyways that was in
there and then there was like also a
shot from birds of prey uh and then
there's like a shot of Aquaman and
Wonder Woman all that stuff and no
Suicide Squad or anything like that or
Peacemaker or anything like that so that
came out and then there's the rest of
the Black Adam shower fine great but
then a lot of people were pointing out
like well why are you showing this clip
from the weed in one what about the
Snyder one also Wheaton's a problem all
this stuff and so then they they changed
the trailer they took out Steppenwolf
entirely uh and they took out most of
the Justice League entirely you still
see all you see from a Zack Snyder film
is the battering in the wall that was
from like dawn of just says yeah Batman
versus Superman Batman v Superman I
apologize
and so then then the rock tweets again
corrected
so poor Rocky I mean I don't I don't
want to kick anyone while they're down
we're all just trying to do our the best
of our jobs that we can and sometimes we
make mistakes and sometimes mistakes got
to be corrected I applaud Warner
Brothers for taking it out but also like
not by not picking I don't even know
what to say I honestly don't know it's
so bizarre and I feel bad for the rock I
feel bad for this movie yeah
and it's been stuck in like
developmental health for so long and
people want to see this movie and they
just want to understand what's going on
at Warner Brothers and Warner Brothers
is like we're working on it guys give us
another we've got a plan by we we mean
no one because there's no one flying
this [ __ ] yeah I said no because I was
told that the trailer that we got uh
during the Buffalo Bills 3110
slaughtering of the Rams was the final
trailer for Black Adam but now there's
another final trailer I think it's the
same trailer like with stuff tacked on
from previous movies
I didn't see any of the trailer during
the Buffalo Bills 41-7 slaughtering of
the titans this week so I wonder if
maybe during their slaughtering of the
Miami Dolphins on Sunday
Talk That Talk
anyway
I believe my Patriots out of this I feel
like uh
and 18 earlier Patriots
um I feel like uh what we have to figure
out is what Black Adam has to do to
further the universe and I feel like
they're they're taking two directions
right they're both they're both saying
it's it's restructuring the hierarchy
and the power structure but it's also
claiming to to be the the forward
momentum so if you have Justice League
tied to that that's that's claiming
Snyder like and and they've been very
clear that the Snyder cut was something
they didn't really have done and we
don't want to keep going that way yeah
so that's the last we know from
corporate was that like the weeded
version is the Canon weird thing to say
yes the Snyder version exists in like
kind of a side Universe it could it's
like the watching the movie clue and
like that's what might have happened or
this could have happened
this way right right but so you have
those and then you have like
you know what uh peacemakers the suicide
squad has done which is kind of
connected and Amanda Waller
yeah crossover and then so there's like
a bridge there and then birds of Praise
attached I would connect none of it I
would like let it and then Shazam is
like also writing that's so direct line
right well Shazam and like Adam have to
connect yeah because black Adam's
referenced in Shazam and then we saw
uh DC EU people from in peace
the Shazam trailer was on by the way
it's all connected now even though in
Shazam they consciously had a different
Batman voice in that too I know I know
toys are this marketing but they seem to
separate all of that just in case did
the Batman just go I'm not Ben Affleck
Adam West and Jason
hello old Chuck this is the side
headline but and it's not even a
headline it's old news but uh I love
when they when people do that uh Tom
Hanks uh his brother does all the Voice
work for like the toys yeah
because it sounds very close to his
brother yeah but that's so great for
your family awesome you want you want
two million for the toys yeah you go do
my voice yeah yeah get over there and be
Woody for a little bit why don't you do
the Woody voice is just like a it's like
a back room bar gangster
get over here
he's like do it again this time sound
more like me hey do me a favor don't
[ __ ] all over my legacy don't shoot all
over my legacy this is what he was
talking about
yeah
oh my God he's right
he's fine
[Laughter]
in the chat with extra the TV show uh
from from d23 we learned that uh we
learned who was cast first for the
Thunderbolts movie and this probably
doesn't comments too much of a surprise
uh but it was Julia Louis-Dreyfus AS Val
basically when they brought her in to be
Val I think they were like because she's
busy doing other stuff like what what is
this and they were like are you gonna
you're gonna show up on the show we're
gonna make a movie called Thunderbolts
and you're gonna be in charge of it and
that was years ago well and then in d23
we saw you know no surprise why it
Russell's in the movie I also like
Sebastian Stan I think that was a big
surprise for everybody they both kind of
found out very recently uh tortured by
it right I do feel bad for a while who
if all they told them was like yeah
you're doing this [ __ ] Winter Soldier
and then we'll figure it out we'll see
and you're supposed to show the first
episode comes out everyone's looking
like you look like the old guy from up
and he's like
this Channel's calling him Johnny
Manny's all the time yeah yeah well
they're calling the character yeah we're
not attacking he did an incredible job
playing yes
I mean it's like you know on the first
like five seasons of Breaking Bad when
everybody was like oh God uh uh what I
can't remember Anna guns
oh she's so [ __ ] she's so devastating
guys she's so frustrated she's such a
stick of them it's like yes that's the
point she's on the right side of the law
and morals here
and by the end you when she finally
breaks mad a little bit you're like oh I
love her now so you're saying uh uh
usage and John Carter's on the right
side of John Carter's in Mars
yes I knew I did it wrong I'm saying
smashing people with with shields in the
face smash him is the right thing to do
um yeah I mean it's been so surprised
that they kept they're probably like
three shows in a movie like I spelled it
out for a while yeah yeah yeah she knows
more than she's like she's supposed to
be in uh in Black Widow first right
wasn't she that was a she was supposed
to appear that was supposed to come out
yeah yeah Blackwater would have come out
before Falcon so that would have been
her first experience so she shot a movie
then a show and then a movie and then
yeah whatever other appearances she has
no idea so she's like comes in in the
middle of an episode on that show right
like it's it's one of the great like oh
my God this is this is a shocking Cameo
and it's like eight minutes into this
episode yeah and she's like carrying her
nine Emmys like yeah I'm Old Christine
yeah hey you know me the real OG uh next
headline uh there was this really fun
clip really fun clip guys they got
posted to Instagram uh from these uh
stunt Fighters stunt Fighters is that
what you doing performers
yeah we don't let women do stunts here
up in Canada
um
anyways it was it was a it was like
we've talked about this channel before
about you know you see like concept art
and stuff this was like a concept fight
for Multiverse of Madness it was like a
one a one or what they call a Wonder In
The Biz like a one single long fight uh
and they basically they had mapped it
out and added some effects to it just in
their little Studio to show this fight
and uh of and it was described as like
Wanda attacking uh uh cometage basically
uh and people were thinking maybe
because we had seen like there was a
concept daughter of her cutting off
mordo's head and like bringing in could
have been this fight or something uh we
won't show I think Dad's like linking in
the chat right now you guys can watch
when you get a chance don't close this
tab when you hear that but it's like a
very great we're afraid to show it
because like it's kind of bloody and
stuff and my dad had all these effects I
mean it's fake but you know yeah I mean
it's very cool someone super chat's two
grand will drop it yeah absolutely it's
very cool watch it check it out but it's
like this one long fight where like
Wanda decapitates someone and then uses
their dead body to fight other people is
it the green bow man that we still have
not no explanations
two scenes of stereo yeah yeah just
showed up no one says oh my God there's
a talking Bowl here that's the last
thing you want to do we confronted with
the talking boat just ignore it that's
true I've been down the wrong road
how cool it is and how I one of my big
problems with Scarlet Witch's Powers is
like we finally get the Scarlet Witch
and then she uses her power to like pew
pew pew like she basically had gun hands
like she just stayed floating was like
What if I appears she was having fun she
was like seven and then like this
actually uses magic it was cool like she
pulled someone up into a box and then
pops them she does things crazy it's
really good and it's very Sam Raimie
like it looks like something he would do
very cool uh R.I.P to the R-rated
version of Multiverse Advantage would
have been great to see yeah check that
out mean you know these things happen
this happens for every movie they work
on these fights that never happen you
know they probably spend two months
working on it and they get a call and
they're like oh we cut that six drafts
ago sorry we didn't tell you guys checks
in the mail uh but very cool yeah a a
variant of a movie we could have had but
I still like Molly version Madness if I
might go on the keeper power
hands all day long fortify your minds
guys hey next deadline
a TV adaptation of David cronobers David
Cronenberg scanners is in the works at
HBO yes uh coming from some of the
creatives who worked on bike mirror and
Lovecraft country uh also R.I.P didn't
get a second season should have uh well
maybe I don't know
I would like to see a second season of
it for sure I am really glad that there
was an actual Cronenberg headline and
that we just weren't talking about yeah
yeah if you were wondering why
this is why uh if you don't know David
Cronenberg uh loves a little body horror
if you're familiar with Wicked Morty
there's a whole Cronenberg Universe
there where people turn into Cronenberg
monsters
pain is their pleasure I will not be
watching this show because it's probably
too scary for me yeah and grotesque but
it sounds like a lot of fun when I was a
boy my dad rented scanners too for us on
VHS because my sister really wanted to
watch a horror movie and in that movie
there's a scene where the female scanner
lady scanner I call her pops up guy in
an NFL football games head well he's
running with the ball and the helmet
just rolls away with blood trickling out
of it and uh yeah I just I just wish
everybody a happy first day of fall
Happy fall equinox happy first day of
fall
autumnal flavors and chunky sweaters
Galore guys put those Beach Bodies away
it's time for these get those leather um
Brown knee-high Boots outlet
get that sweater and exercise up don't
worry Don't Be Afraid males and females
to wear some spandex leggings yeah go
for it let it Let It Fly Just bathe in
pumpkin spice it's the seasons tis the
season enters the season for our next
headline yes M Night shyamalan's back
baby his next film knock at the cabin
has released its first trailer the film
is based on the novel The Cabin at the
end of the world never stay at that
Kevin uh the movie stars Dave Batista
our very own Dave Batista uh and
Frozen's Jonathan Gruff is that the
dummy wrote in the credits for these
people Frozen's Jonathan he's one of the
one you know him we have a quick clip of
the trailer to show you guys Dave
Batista in action
we were called and are united by a
common vision
which has now become a command
that we cannot ignore
[Music]
the four of us are here
to prevent the Apocalypse
your family has been chosen to make a
horrible decision
if you fail to choose
the world will end
Dave you had a great match with Triple H
last time you're around give me what I
want Hunter yeah uh we'd love to see you
back but I understand he's got it he's
killing it he's going out there uh you
guys trust stole them night Shaman uh
does he won back your trust he never
lost it
oh that's the Airbender really made me
um
I heard old was decent people like dogs
I think this is a good Avenue for him
like kind of Cheaper horror movies
as good as signs unbreakable and in my
opinion sixth sense sorry Sixth Sense my
opinion signs yeah he's the only one
that's it is you get forever I'll see it
like I'll try I I'm part of a little
crew called the Knights of the Round
Table and we are just uh fan boys and
girls of M Night Shyamalan shoots a lot
of his exteriors in Upstate New York
shout out to that region I don't know if
you know I'm from there uh I hadn't
heard that before and I am uh yeah I say
keep letting night cook you know uh
there cannot be day without okay that's
enough for that yeah we got a mega chat
from someone Cory's gonna do it do a
wedding dress for us and that was a
blink if you miss it Rupert Grint there
on the right uh uh Ron Weasley is back I
thought it was koi for a second guys
that's why I'm so excited about it
thank you for the super chats you Capri
to sing uh let's just catty do whatever
the Redemption is today my mom's right
now
oh this is for Wong okay okay come over
and give us a wedding toast wedding and
feel free to name Wong's partner yeah
who's the one getting married too
I've known Wong a very long time uh Wong
is a man who loves his sandwiches he's
big on rye sourdough certain types of
charcuterie but mainly his focus is on
ice cream and and all the time I've
known Wong the only thing he's loved
more than sandwiches and ice cream is
Madison and she is as surprising as a
cup of Nestle Crunch ice cream because
the Y is not where you think uh when
they met there was such a profound love
and and shared chemistry over the
chemistry of alcohol mixing uh the only
thing I'm worried about in their
lifelong betrothal is
alcoholism so I would like uh as his
best friend best man and Godfather to
their children oh wow so to warn all of
you just keep an eye on the drinking the
ice cream the sandwiches I wish them
well I wish them happiness but at the
end of the day they did meet while she
was bartering with demons with her blood
drunk on gin and tonics so I worry about
any relationships with the starts there
it can end well but we'll see and I love
them both good night cheers wow cheers
to wongers and alleys that's a tough
that's a tough toast it's a tough toast
[Laughter]
thank you
Umberto am sent in a Super Chat and he
said Team this is my third ever Super
Chat he's keeping score guys wow but
don't get a shout out on the previous
two crying face emoji keep the content
coming y'all a great fist Emoji that's
our bad that's our bad we don't you know
we can't get to them all uh and thank
you Frank girl She-Hulk is such a
daredevil tease
you could create that we know you're in
cahoots with film juice and we
appreciate your super chats but we don't
appreciate the comments okay we know the
bills don't suck as a matter of fact we
know they're awesome they didn't even
spell it right there you go oh so you
should go you should be able to read it
Tommy yeah that's true also Franco did
ask uh uh if you were getting married
what would your color scheme be I did
get married thank God that's over with
uh you know I had a lot of fun and my my
wedding colors were whatever my wife
wanted them as if they were jewel tones
jewel tones look at Navy forest green is
what I'd want but it's not up to me
mine's gonna be all black everywhere oh
I love it I like everything Johnny Cash
style mine isn't going to be a color
scheme is going to be more so a giant
Banner of my face
on the altar because it's my day too God
damn that's right my day two but just my
face yeah yeah just only my face not my
wife you know you should all come out of
your mouth you know I mean like a
carnival like ah like AstroWorld yeah
yeah
that's beautiful uh we got one last
headline for you and it's very important
so uh you need to pay attention this is
for all you you your Pratt racks out
there you know uh you know I'm from uh
Sony Pictures passengers I believe that
was a Sony Pictures joined Chris Pratt
some some say he's the best Chris I
didn't say that you all know my one for
Chris Pine uh but uh uh I love
Christopher mint's plan
so Chris Brown he's joined the voice of
Super Mario now in a super Mario's
Brothers film I don't know if it's
brother's film it's a Super Mario film
oh well I think someone else I can't
confirm that it's a brother Luigi young
confirmed I think Luigi's been cast has
he I don't know uh it's definitely not
John no it's not I don't think this is
live action right this is
the voice we're getting a teaser trailer
on October 6 at New York Comic Con yeah
are you gonna be there quiet do you have
plans I'm I'm very excited for whatever
we might have to put a GoPro yeah
reaction to Mario I have I mean I I have
very little desire to see
but I am interested in just seeing I
want to see what they're going to do I'm
very interested to see I'm Mario wow
this is crazy I'm a plumber wow I'm
Mario this accent isn't offensive at all
cause I'm Super Mario
I don't know well we did ask you guys in
a poll uh do you want Black Adam to be
in its own universe or part of the sign
of verse uh and those two options it's
pretty split down the middle you did say
you're on a universe something you said
Snyder verse I don't know I don't think
we'll ever see this side of verse ever
again I'm afraid they they've just
locked it away they've locked it away
forever but there are three Snyder verse
I think they're done and three
characters remain I don't know yeah it
seems like they've worked so hard to
separate everything but just Smash and
then like we have Aquaman filming more
scenes of Manassas
the comics everything happens in the
comics at the same time they're all just
smashing it's all just smashed together
just do it no one well we're all
watching yeah we'll see you there we're
just consumers let us consume uh folks
let's get to our main topic today uh you
know we we've got a long time in the MCU
without an Avengers movie it's been it's
been a while ever since endgame uh but
now we've got two on the schedule for
phase six we're very excited uh and it's
been confirmed that the writing has
begun or is about to begin for Avengers
Kang Dynasty uh which that script is
being headed up by Jeff Jeff loveness
who most recently wrote ant-manuel's
quantumania uh and was a writer on Rick
and Morty and a bunch of other things uh
and he's been kind of funny on Twitter
funny on Twitter she's he's supposed to
kind of funny things on Twitter about
this whole idea of him getting to write
this movie and people give him
congratulations he did write it put up a
tweet that was like he asked how do you
write a movie
and he got a lot of great responses uh
to this tweet one of the top ones being
like Story Circle right which was like a
big thing on Rick and Morty and
Community it's like a Dan Harmon uh
concept that he preaches he didn't come
up with the story Circle but it's like a
thing that he preaches right this idea
uh and then he put out like another
tweet when like the news came out where
he was joking like oh I'm gonna shoot it
this weekend in the backyard uh does
anyone have like a camera and a battery
can you bring it uh that kind of thing
Snyder did do that for the snyderco I
know he hits you think that his house uh
and of course Jeff wadness came up kind
of in like the internet comedy community
uh I think he did some like Channel 101
stuff more than likely where like you
kind of just film things on your own
really run a gun that kind of stuff he
got some interesting replies to like oh
can you come shooting it this weekend uh
Demi dujaway Bay uh like he's a comedy
writer he got offered the role of like
uh Moon Knight another writer comedian
Jamie Loftus got offered the world to be
Vision uh and then his like original
tweet he kind of said like anyone if
anyone can bring a boom might you can be
Iron Man very funny very jokey right War
Machine boom boom you're looking for
this can you hear it it's over here
like very funny and joking right but do
you think there's like any amount of
seriousness to it or like could he be
like Tuesday like oh I'd love to put
Vision in this or Moon not in this or
even an Iron Man in there this is a
Freudian slim these are just the
characters he's thinking about like
that's one or two of those are just like
accidentally just revealing or on
purpose the entire cast list throughout
like over the next two years he's like
he's like I don't know last night I had
a real Hawkeye when I spotted a black
widow over in my kindling from my
fireplace
it's getting late for fireplace Scarlet
Witch makes sense I guess you could say
there was a human torch would I have
okay okay
but yeah I think they're okay there
could be something
there could be something that says you
know Jamie Loftus is dope and a lot of
the other communities he interacted with
on Twitter are also cool uh but yeah
like we haven't seen white Vision since
the end of world division uh and Moon
Knight those are two white guys I'd love
to see it okay Dynasty uh White vision
and Moon Knight
um but yeah like this could be a joke
you think he might sneak in an
accidental or on purpose
casting or character Revelation in these
like jokey tweets yeah it's a
it's fine to get to this point in my
mind with with Marvel Studios where you
know Loki comes out it's a big success
you know I don't know and the green
light a season two while season one's
kind of coming out of being successful
it makes me wonder at one point they
were like okay's the way to go or if
they were just kind of like trying out
things to see what they like they like
Kang they like the Multiverse stuff they
bring in a couple writers from Rick and
Morty where there's tons of Multiverse
discussion uh this is I think right now
like in a pop culture sense so many
movies are touching on Multiverse you
see is trying to do it with a Flash
movie that may never come out uh you
know any and even like a movie like
everywhere everything everywhere all at
once which very much made the concept of
a Multiverse accessible to audiences
like this is like what they're doing and
so they bring in these Rick and Morty
writers they tap Jeff loveness to write
Ant-Man and was quantumania and they
really like it and they like what he's
doing so they're like yeah keep this
story going you seem to have a firm
grasp of this yeah in addition at d23
during the Loki section of the Marvel
panel they were like looking this show
is very important to what's happening
and is like really establishing what
we're going to see and ostensibly maybe
the same Kang in quantumania will be in
like the same Kang and Loki 2. uh so I
imagine Loki's got to make it to Secret
Wars right I also Imagine Kang we'll
have to see a few iterations of him
before we get to Daddy Kang right like I
think that we're gonna see him in and
we're gonna see some kegs get killed
exactly so I think Loki might be good
like because you want that long form
time yeah we might see like two or three
kings in Ant-Man but I think we'll see a
lot of kangs and Loki leading up to the
King Dynasty because you need to
understand the concept of all of these
different Kings and right now in the
comics there's this really interesting
storyline where Kang finally had his own
solo title and he basically was going
through time chasing his love and he had
to accept that the love was the thing
that fueled his rage and that if he
accomplished the love then he'd never be
Kang so it was him accepting his own
machine yeah it was really fun for him
to be like everything I want is the
thing I can't have most it was this
really dark story and I'd love if they
were able to spend enough time with him
like the Beth Thanos where you kind of
justify why he's a conqueror why you
justify so I think it would be
beneficial to have a a movie set him up
as this Kang a show elaborate the Kings
leading up to the Kang Dynasty where you
have to fight him a la Infinity war end
game like I think we really need to be
invested in him before we get anywhere
close to this so I love that they've got
the same writer on this journey like
he's going with them on this whole thing
yeah and now they're also brought in we
know that Dustin Dustin Daniel credit is
directing uh uh Kang Dynasty do you
think they're gonna tie in something for
Zhang XI there like is that a connection
there they've kind of teased these these
jewelry pieces right that sounds like
it's building
yeah the Rings the the the bangle uh
maybe Moonlight stuff
yeah well we did see it yeah we saw like
a Kang
uh uh picture yes uh when he's the the
Egyptian pharaoh yeah
I think you're right
I think
uh so like obviously there's connections
there so I would love to see all of that
come through and be connected in a fun
way do you think do you think uh this
like that his like jokey Iron Man tweet
they're gonna have to I there's no way
they don't bring back a dead person for
one of these movies for a cameo
at one point in in Marvel's near future
they're gonna pull that rip cord right
whether it's we see Steve Rogers not
dead necessarily but last we saw him
very old like bringing back like a young
Chris Evans as a Steve Rogers from
Another Universe or like uh a Robert
Downey Jr or a black widow I mean
they've already kind they already kind
of played that hand with Gamora right
they killed Gamora only to like bring
back one from out of time same universe
but like just brought out of time and I
feel like that's a really slippery slope
to where it becomes the comics where
like death is is irrelevant right and I
do worry that especially with the big
two you know we've had that perfect
x-arc that I talk about all the time
where you know cap and Steve kind of
switch places in the acts of Civil War
and the selfless selfish all those
things I do worry that if you bring it
back even for Cameo it does even if it's
another Universe it does kind of
invalidate that like their death is I
mean no matter what if I see down in
junior I'm not gonna go like but not
mine down junior so like I personally
don't want them to but I mean it depends
on how deep we go into phase six I mean
I want him to do it before they deep
fake it right before we get the digital
yeah digital Downey Jr coming back man
that's not going to be a digital Johnny
is what they call their middle school DJ
they might bring in for cap and Iron Man
variants yeah I think that's the more
likely thing I don't think Robert Downey
Jr or Steve Steve Evans Chris Evans who
will reprise their roles as captain Iron
Man like
very easy to be like here's cap from the
227 universe
[Laughter]
we will see Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man
in an MCU movie again it will happen
again when they do it is like the big
question and like I could see them
pulling it out for the one of these two
Avengers movies because both of them are
dealing with timelines and realities and
separate things these are our next two
Avengers movie those that mean we didn't
have an Avengers movie without them
us
[Music]
face Us in the octagon
and the hand combat now there is one
actor that I really hope that Jeff
lovedness Taps uh uh for the for secret
or for Kang Dynasty I don't know if the
writer gets to tap actors yeah uh but if
you get a call I I think we have a photo
of Jeff loveness with this actor
oh wow yeah the actor Ever foreign
at that point he wouldn't even touch
Indiana Jones five yeah that was a very
young time that was your natural hair
that was yeah they they bunded up for me
they bunded up for you beautiful stuff
um well I think we're all excited for uh
a little King Dyson I'm excited to get
back to the Avengers I'm I'm really
interested to see how they're gonna get
us back there because they don't have a
lot of time no they've called a lot of
their movies out already so I'm like
okay well I see I think New World Order
is when they're really starting to
perform like another Avengers team also
with those gaps in the face six I'm
really curious what fills those since we
didn't get the announcement yeah there's
a lot of those yeah I think it's gonna
be more shows than movies I think they
could do I mean I don't think those
three spots are the only spots I think I
think that's gonna be spots more secret
spots maybe we'll find out a New York
guys Doom confirmed you're a Comic-Con
okay
seeing that photo gives me some
aspiration I also want to thank
this week making small decisions every
day to help the planet can have a big
impact over time me and I drink out of
this delicious mug instead of the
Disposable coffee cups I was so addicted
to for so many years I love the crunch
in my hand as I forsake them but now
I just used this mug if you keep money
in your most standard in most standard
bank accounts they're letting your
deposits out to fund oil and coal switch
to the planted side and get aspiration
aspiration is a climate friendly
alternative to Big Banks get an account
and debit card that is fossil fuel free
and you can even plant a tree by
rounding up every swipe of your debit
card cha-ching into the ground
aspiration's been hard at work funding
the plenty of over 100 million trees on
the way to funding the planting of 1
billion trees by 2030. best of all
there's no credit check and that's you
know for Big Daddy that's important no
overdraft fees my credit score is no
[Applause]
you just pay what you think is fair even
if that's zero because money shouldn't
stand in the way of you doing the right
thing tell that to my landlord make your
dollars make a difference open an
aspiration account at aspiration.com
break room debit and move your money out
of fossil fuels baby help save the
planet with their aspiration debit card
open your account at aspirations.com
break room debit today that is
aspiration.com break room debit terms
and conditions apply and we also got to
thank oh brand near and dear my heart
Lands End you ever received some of that
promo shirts uh and swag from a con or a
trade show and you're just looking at it
and you're like this is going to go in
my closet someday to be donated to
Goodwill or thrown away or given as a
gag gift it's low quality and
uncomfortable if you're trying to
promote your business you should have
the best promo material available 1000
thousands of businesses have relied on
lands and business to outfit their
employees and promote their brand you
could have your logo and Vivid colors on
a t-shirt I'm talking moov taupe oh
beige aubergine clear I think that's
just a French word for eggplant yeah
aubergine's in the chat water bottles
and more don't do that to them hundreds
of products perfect for any trade show
event or holiday gift every business is
treated like a VIP whether you have a
five employees or 500 but if you have
four you're SOL with their business with
their awesome customer service I'm just
kidding if you got four get them all
fleece best baby yeah fleece vest is the
best way you guys have a bowling team
right there I'm absolutely certain
Philip Molina is listening to this right
now he better be going to Lands End
Business to get me something nice for
Kris kringle's jingle jangle this year
see why thousands of companies count on
Lands End Business go to
business.landsand.com com slash podcast
and use that promo code podcast for 25
off that's Lands End dot or I'm sorry
that's business dot lands end.com slash
podcast promo code podcast for 25 off
that's a quarter off oh yeah baby off
the vest they got the Aborigines in the
chat yeah all right
hey it's not a mandatory [ __ ] yeah no
worse no the segment that gets me all
excited from my Hooten holler to my
silver dollar
I really liked it
sorry guys I broke him
it's the segment with the graphic so
exciting we keep the graphic coming
daily and nighting hit it again
[Applause]
you know you're welcome to step in okay
all right see it up I'll finish it
it's the segment so Boombastic
we gotta run it bastic
yes all right
now fantastic
mandatory fun listen
people are coming back to the MCU Fast
and Furious we know the leader will be
back yeah in uh New World Order maybe
sooner with big green head what you guys
don't know is that the four of us here
these are my three best friends by the
way a mandatory fund we uh get my two
three best friends together to do some
fun but they have no choice but to
participate in
the four of us are actually Talent
agents we live we live in Canada but we
get a lot of uh we get a lot of work we
get a lot of talent uh up there we
represent superheroes so much like
She-Hulk is a superhero Attorney at Law
in the superhero division we represent
Heroes and right now we're all gonna put
on our agent glasses and we're gonna
pitch one of our star clients to slowly
get back into the MCU yeah I mean we
were just talking about King Dynasty
they're gonna need some new heroes and
villains for this that's right we got
clients that we want to get into this
movie yeah we we got to show off who we
think should be there
do you want to go first time I could
sure
let me put these on real quick get in
get in the zone yeah there you go
that was an AutoZone yesterday oh
good reason I should have went to two
Auto Zones
hey everybody how you doing my last time
back go back to main street hey hey I
want to talk to you all about someone so
fantastic oh my gosh so irreverent so
special a special kind of talent that
only comes around once a year you want
to get nailed hire Justin Hammer Ah
that's right is he dead from that one
shot we don't know we don't know I'll
never tell Justin is working Bottom
Dollar right now okay he will work for
free he will pay you he's Rich he will
give you money to let him be in your
film Justin Hammer just let him Hammer
you with his talent okay listen to me
right now foggy foggy I've known you a
long time I've seen you in some pretty
compromising positions I've seen you get
your face painted at Jumbo's Clown Room
with without any makeup brushes if you
know what I mean they paint you with the
bodies Kevin I got the evidence okay
Kathleen Kennedy I've seen you too so
we're coming for Star Wars next look at
these super cats rolling into my boy
Justin Hammer let me tell you something
you gotta get my boy up there okay it's
hammer time please hammer don't hurt him
beautiful stuff beautiful thank you
thank you beautiful thank you thank you
do either of you have a client you would
like to represent you would go first
put on the ancient glasses hey let's see
your best cell
all right so I got a guy oh okay he's uh
uh young pretty boy
sleeveless costume oh boy oh iconic
graphic whoa blues and reds pop on
screen
blonde trendy haircut what are you
talking about here I got you Ben Riley
whoa spider oh yeah think about Ben
Riley Scarlet Spider is he's the uh the
younger funner uh brother let's call him
a Peter Parker oh okay I'm gonna suggest
you you hire this Andrew Garfield guy
wow I hear he gets real method I hear
he's real spunky yeah
real real full of life and vigor and uh
I just feel like you know Ben Riley he's
like if if power and responsibility went
awry like perhaps you'd have some sort
of existential crisis and see yourself
as a younger funner version yourself dye
your hair blonde go on a walkabout come
back have a whole clone saga but I'm
gonna say Ben Riley is our way to get
our boy into Garfield back in how are my
guy Scarlet Spider candy great stuff I
love it a cool O'Reilly
Auto Parts I can't believe you just gave
him a freak
first one's free
you all are Pawns of the corporate
Master
my horse just died see it's not it's a
negative that was good hey yo Captain
baby
sorry I just came in I'm sorry I'm
running so late hey hey it's hard to get
across down the traffic on the 10 today
can you believe they're doing
construction I will [ __ ] oh every day
with this hey I hear you got a new movie
coming together I got a guy okay well I
had him in one movie I haven't used them
again he's just sitting there you're
bringing back this friend in another
movie he's an older guy but you got the
D aging technology we could have
flashbacks in this movie baby I'm
talking about a big name in Hollywood
whoa and it only gets bigger My Boy Bill
Foster
oh Goliath Don't Call Him black Goliath
that's old school we call him just
Goliath okay don't do with the old
Marvel stuff said bring it back put him
in a movie you had him show up for 10 he
didn't even get big he talked about
getting big he didn't let him get big
you got the technology bring back my boy
Bill Foster okay but I mean that you've
got ghosts coming back who remembers
ghosts people don't want to buy ghost
toys they want to buy Bill Foster toys
that's where the money is bring it back
let's have a flashback scene
just do it Kevin I gotta go I gotta get
back out of here you validate parking do
I validate wow I didn't I saw you I
thought I saw you roll up off of a city
bus I did take a city bus but do you
validate so what do you just want us to
give you some cash yeah you got a dollar
eight okay guys can we get everybody get
your pocket change out for this guy this
Valley just a bus transport right
all right all right oh I Almost Got Away
it's got cleaned
all right I'm gonna go up and pitch my
client real fast uh Hey Kevin how you
doing we go back we go back a long time
as do me and my client my client needs
to be in these upcoming Marvel movies
especially Kang Dynasty my client is
beautiful voluptuous she is fantastic
she's made numbers happen for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe before she is Jessica
Alba's sister
and proper
fantastic horror movie coming out or as
a variant now look
gen Z they're gonna go bananas when she
sits when she comes on the screen people
who fell in love with her and Gabrielle
Union show The Bad Boys TV show that was
on ATT Plus or whatever that was a bad
boy there surely was that was two girls
stop asking questions
most people gonna tune in and buy a
whole lot of tickets to see you soon
storm played by Jessica
Millennials that remember Dark Angel oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I was fell in love
with Jessica Alba kicking butt well
those of us that remember Idle Hands
fell in love in that tank top you're
making my point for me so look Kevin
don't be obtuse all right don't be up
too you need Jessica Alba in upcoming
Marvel films as to storm no it stands or
what's about it oh yeah her butt in
effect
yeah we'll sell all the tickets you need
to sell and do numbers in China all
right now oh my gosh
uh we did have an episode of She-Hulk
last night we did some fantasy we did
some fantasy predictions for the show uh
uh we'll we'll get we'll do a full
update for you next week but just so you
know uh quite did pretty well he's he's
leading everyone with 46 points chat you
were smart to go with koi because he did
the most points on the show last night
uh chat you're at like 40 points right
now so you're about the middle of the
field there's a couple other people on
staff ahead of you some a few behind you
uh but Coy is leading right now uh so
but we'll do a full update next week
before we do our fancy picks for the
next show and that'll be great spend
that we have time let's do a wedding
toast I'm in the mood for a wedding
oh
what happened to his previous wife she
died
oh they're so happy Tommy hot guy oh no
I mean this
from my toast maker to my dump tank
you and I go so far back
you've known me since I was a little boy
shoving food into my pork Chopper coming
out my clop dropper oh my God you know
what I'm saying Clint you never miss
you never miss and now you never misses
because this is your lady you're here
you're marrying
Titania oh that's a reveal a brand
influencer no one ever thought it was
possible I thought love was dead when
your wife's name escapes me die
and you and I have known each other
since we were little boys eating
Starburst and crap until it hurts oh my
God all right
we've been friends we've seen it all you
spearfishing with perfect accuracy it's
me hooking myself with a traditional
fish hook through my mouth it's still
reeling in thinking I caught something
you always wear the brains of the
operation and I thought I was the eyes
but in the end you were the hot guy and
I simply a man with a hawk heart thanks
to my surgeon Dr nasty who put a beating
Hall card into my chest yesterday to you
Clint [ __ ]
hey he was playing a character folks hey
he's playing a character at a wedding oh
is she really that likable on TV I'm
sorry I don't see what she's done wrong
I'm back sorry that was just a character
guys oh what a character wow what a guy
what a character in it uh uh Eric you'll
be good to know that everyone likes your
pictures oh thank you very good that was
wonderful dark angel that was a James
Cameron show right there
oh you got me through a lot of nights
during high schools Archangel uh Fridays
are the best nights ever yes they were
uh remember when you watched TV on
Friday right now nothing else to do on a
Friday man I'm going Boomer on you guys
apologies I was born in 2002. don't
forget thank you all super Chatters
today
you're checking I'm such a Sim it
definitely sucks I'm thinking that you
can preach the setting on a ton of super
chats today yeah
my morbid time mug just arrived but it
said Bills suck oh
Zach we have a common enemy Mikey Mikey
cheer sending a Super Chat saying we
need Ben Reilly got to be a darker
Andrew though darker Andrew the Andrew
Garfield in no way home was pretty dark
[Music]
he hasn't gone on a date for 10 years uh
Mike whatever saying does your morbid
time say more more than Tim on one side
mine is extra rare
hey you know what when when reality and
fiction are so blurred that you have no
idea I don't know what's real Frank send
us a DM and with a pic with picture
proof of that if you DM me proof of that
most Tiny Tim's cousin yeah I think he's
Wolverine thank you the
mj2997 uh thank you Christian
unpronounceable should we go for read
one of Yuka prado's ones uh that said oh
no it's in the Super Chat oh okay it
says something about the vibranium beads
[Music]
oh well we're here we aren't going to
get a chance to talk about Andor today
generally but we are going to talk about
it tomorrow and more or so on Monday so
catch up on those episodes this show is
good it's good
do not be one of those people that is
going to be contrarian watch this show
and join us in the conversation this
show is awesome it's a really good story
we're not at some Disney red carpet
being forced to say we like it with guns
to our heads we're in Pacoima they can't
there's no more shows
Disney Plus in Canada yeah it's just
called hulux this time uh you complete
that did send in a Super Chat saying we
need more vibranium beads in the MCA and
don't forget to sign up for your
subscriptions to thrust Guys numbers
have been down y'all need Jesus y'all
need Jesus uh it does make me think
there is quite a scandal going on in the
Chess World right now yes that does
involve uh beads yeah and I suggest you
look it up slate had a very good article
about it what's going on in the world
there are some accusations that people
are cheating at chess involving some
beans that are signaling them yeah when
to make certain moves and how to make
certain moves and where they put those
beads is up to you to figure out you
want to know how I won my Checkers
tournament is it like Morse code uh I
think it's something communicating it's
something to that nature
um
uh thank you for joining us today we
hope you come back tomorrow Fridays are
a little more unhinged today
so be sure to join us hit that like
button if you haven't already uh join
our Discord oh my God Jessica will be
back for something
we apologize yeah we apologize we thank
you guys for tuning in today join the
Discord sending clips of the week
sending voicemails send in call in if
you're listening right now yeah uh we
hope you have a great rest of your
Thursday we'll see you all tomorrow
latest Gators adios and goodbye
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
thank you
[Music]